In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 12 on which we commemorate our righteous father
Biasios the Athenite.
On July 25 in the year 1924, the future elder Biasios was born to pious parents in the town
of Farrassa, Cappadocia, of Asia Minor.
The family's spiritual father, the priest monk Arsenios, the now canonized Saint Arsenios
of Cappadocia, baptized the babe with his own name, prophesying his future profession
as a monk.
A week after the baptism and barely a month after his birth, Arsenios was driven along with
his family out of Asia Minor by the Turks.
Saint Arsenios guided his flock along their 400-mile track to Greece.
After a number of stops along the way, Arsenios' family finally ended up in the town of
Conezzen Epidos.
Saint Arsenios had reposed as he had prophesied 40 days after their establishment in Greece,
and he left as his spiritual heir, the infant Arsenios.
The young Arsenios was wholly given over to God and spent his free time in the silence
of nature, where he would pray for hours on end.
Having completed his elementary education, he learned the trade of carpentry.
He worked as a carpenter until his mandatory military service.
He served in the army during the dangerous days of the end of World War II.
Arsenios was brave and self-sacrificing, always desiring to put his own life at risk, so as
to spare his brother.
He was particularly concerned about his fellow soldiers who had left wives and children
to serve.
Having completed his obligation to his country, Arsenios received his discharge in 1949, and
greatly desired to begin his monastic life on the Holy Mountain.
Before being able to settle there, however, he had to fulfill his responsibility to his family,
to look after his sisters, who were as yet unmarried.
Having provided for his sister's future, he was free to begin his monastic vocation
with the clean conscience.
In 1950 he arrived on Mount Athos, where he learned his first lessons in the monastic way
from the virtuous ascetic Father Kiddil, the future abbot of Kutlumusio monastery.
But he was unable to stay at his side as he had hoped, and so was sent to the monastery
of Esfigmenu.
He was a novice there for four years, after which he was transferred a monk in 1954, with
the name of Erkios.
He was a conscientious monk, finding ways to both complete his obedience, which required contact
with others, and to preserve his silence, so as to progress in the art of prayer.
He was always selfless in helping his brethren, unwilling to rest while others worked, though
he may have already completed his own obedience, as he loved his brothers greatly and without
distinction.
In addition to his ascetic struggles and the common life in the monastery, he was spiritually
enriched through the reading of soul-propheting books.
In particular, he read the lives of the saints, the Yerantikon, and especially the ascetical
homelies of St. Isaac the Syrian.
Soon after his tonsure, monk Abirkios left Esfigmenu and joined the then-irrorithmic brotherhood
of Philotheum monastery, where his uncle was a monk.
He put himself under obedience to the virtuous Elder Simeon, who gave him the small schema
in 1956, with the new name Baesios.
Father Baesios dwelt deeply on the thought that his own spiritual failures and lack of love
were the cause of his neighbor's shortcomings, as well as of the world's ills.
He harshly accused himself, pushing himself to greater self-denial, and more fervent prayer
for his soul and for the whole world.
Furthermore, he cultivated the habit of always seeking the good reason for a potentially scandalous
event and for people's actions, and in this way he preserved himself from judging others.
For example, pilgrims to mount Athos had been scandalized by the strange behavior and
stories told by a certain monk, and when they met Elder Baesios, they asked him what was
wrong with the monk.
He warned them not to judge others, and that this monk was actually virtuous and was simply
pretending to be a fool when visitors would come, so as to preserve his silence.
In 1958, Elder Baesios was asked to spend some time in and around his home village of
Gonitsa, so as to support the faithful against the proselytism of Protestant groups.
He greatly encouraged the faithful there, helping many people.
Afterwards, in 1962, he left to visit Sinai, where he stayed for two years.
During this time, he became beloved of the Bedouins, who benefited both spiritually as well
as materially from his presence.
The Elder used the money he received from the sale of his carved wooden handicrafts to
buy them food.
On his return to mount Athos in 1964, Elder Baesios took up residence at the Skiti of Ividon
before moving to Katunakia at the southernmost tip of Mount Athos, for a short stay in the
desert there.
The Elder's failing health may have been part of the reason for his departure from the
desert.
In 1966, he was operated on, and had part of his lungs removed.
It was during this time of hospitalization that his long friendship with the then young
sisterhood of St. John the Theologian in Surati, just outside of Thessaloniki, began.
During his operation, he greatly needed blood, and it was then that a group of novices,
from the monastery, donated blood to save him.
Elder Baesios was most grateful, and after his recovery did whatever he could, materially
and spiritually, to help them build their monastery.
In 1968, he spent time at the monastery of Stavronikita, helping with its spiritual, as well
as material, renovation.
While there, he had the blessing of being in contact with the ascetic Elder Tykon, who
lived in the hermitage of the Holy Cross near Stavronikita.
Elder Baesios stayed by his side until his repose, serving himselflessly as his disciple.
It was during this time that Elder Tykon clothed Father Baesios in the great schema.
According to the wishes of the Elder, Father Baesios remained in his hermitage after his
repose.
He stayed there until 1979, when he moved on to his final home on the Holy Mountain,
the hermitage of Panaguda, which belongs to the monastery of Kotlin Musil.
It was here at Panaguda that Elder Baesios' fame, as a god-bearing elder, grew, drawing
to him the sick and suffering people of God.
He received them all day long, dedicating the night to God in prayer, visual, and spiritual
struggle.
His regime of prayer and asceticism, with which he served God and his fellow-man, his
strictness with himself, the austerity of his regime, and his sensitive nature, made him
increasingly prone to sickness.
In addition to respiratory problems, in his later days he suffered from a serious
hernia that made life very painful.
When he was forced to leave the Holy Mountain for various reasons, often due to his illness,
he would receive pilgrims for hours on end at the women's monastery at Surat-i and the
physical effort which this entailed in his weakened state caused him such pain that he
would turn pale.
He bore his suffering with much grace, however, confident that, as God knows what is best
for us, it could not be otherwise.
He would say that God is greatly touched when someone who is in great suffering does not complain,
but rather uses his energy to pray for others.
In addition to his other illness, he suffered from hemorrhaging which left him very weak.
In his final weeks before leaving the Holy Mountain, he would often fall unconscious.
On the 5th of October in 1993, the elder left his beloved Holy Mountain for the last
time.
Although he had planned on being off the mountain for just a few days, while in Thessaloniki he
was diagnosed with cancer that needed immediate treatment.
After the operation he spent some time recovering in the hospital and was then transferred to
the monastery at Surat-i.
Despite his critical state, he received people listening to their sorrow and counseling them.
After his operation, elder Paesios had his heart set on returning to Mount Athos.
His attempts to do so, however, were hindered by his failing health.
His last days were full of suffering, but also of the joy of the martyrs.
On July 11, 1994, he received Holy Communion for the last time.
The next day, elder Paesios gave his soul into God's keeping.
He was buried according to his wishes at the monastery of St. John the Theologian in Surat-i.
Elder Paesios, perhaps more than any other contemporary elder, has captured the minds
and hearts of Greek people.
Many books of his councils have been published, and the monastery at Surat-i has undertaken
a great work, organizing the elder's writings and councils into impressive volumes, benefiting
his memory.
Thousands of pilgrims visit his grave each year, so as to receive his blessing.
Elder Paesios, the Athenite, was glorified as a saint by the Holy Synod of the Patriarchate
of Constantinople on January 13, 2015.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.